si vous deviez vous confesser
aujourd'hui aux téléspectateurs qu'est
ce que vous diriez les mecs à lever
mois-là climat parce que là je vais
mourir
maintenant qu'ils pensent et le meilleur
homard mais ce qui me regarde et même le
numérique n'a pas envie moi ça qu'est ce
que c'est ça sait d'où ça vient c'est
donc ça vient c'est donc s'avérer
tornade blanche
alors si vous avez un truc a confessé
aujourd'hui allez-y enlevez moi la team
mathieu de langues o moi parce que c'est
grave ou pas d'avoir volé beaucoup
d'argent à cri à moi et non mes parents
oui parce que mon père laisser sa baisse
le soir ils rentrent à chaque fois il
peut déposer sa baisse comme ça a été
chaud c'est ce problème du whisky et
puis j'ai vu son portefeuille achats pas
parfait je prenais un billet paf
problème vient quasiment tous les soirs
non je pense que cette phase a fait un
très gros montants ah oui ça voudrait
acheter votre porsche non
tu veux de porsche sa vie entre potes
vous aviez une porsche mais je me sens
un peu d'ordre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand on roule à 30 allant dans pareils
qu'on respecte mon avenir n'a pas de
porsche ah oui j'avais une porsche à man
ouest
j'ai cru que c'était peut-être un porche
a coûté je vous emmerde
non mais c'est vrai donc voilà donc vous
voliez d'argent votre père il a su il le
sait où ils devaient le sait ce soir ne
pense qu'ils le découvrent mais peut se
gratter pour me demander
qu'est ce que je pourrais confessé à la
volée un rocher suchard
j'étais très trop garde quand j'étais
petit dont je voulais pas moi mais
j'étais du bon élève mais non peut-être
d'avoir tous d'avoir envie de envie de 2
1 ap 2 toujours plus il faudrait que
ouais patoche ça va rouler pas toujours
plus non mais c'est vrai quoi il est
magnifique arrêter maintenant ça fait
très longtemps que j'ai pas bu il a dans
la fois que j'ai vu il avait déjà sur
cinq ans et pas du tout mais non il a
quel âge et à 55 ans non ça va gan
d'habitude on confessionnal je ressors
avec des paternoster à faire parce que
je dis que j'ai regardé été pmp là étant
donné que j'ai fait
je sais
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais compris
un happening à la bible qui vous sortir
et donc non nobles voilà ce que j'ai a
confessé rien y regarder il est dedans
n'a idée de ce qu'est ce que je suis on
me dit pas tout quoi qu'il dise tu
connais la sa vie non non moi n'a
forcément mais toi tu es connell vous
marrez elle elle confesse qu'elle est
trop bien fonctionnera si c'est vrai lui
confesse qu'il est hantée pmp
jamais la raison que je me faisais un
peu tourner ma vie mon jeu a trompé
tomber non
jamais une orgie
[Musique]
chiant de toute ta vie d'anna c'est vrai
que
si la droiture morale être chiant alors
je remonte de 4 chiffres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mathieu qui je quitte là bas c'est ça
mais voilà alors isabelle zanette
confession à faire vous vous êtes vous
oui pas mettre assez occupé de mon mari
ça continue non c'est vrai ça c'est
mignon ça assez mignon c'est vrai ah bah
ouais mais lui ça le faisait parce
qu'ils me le reproche wave ou leurs
proches c'est vrai pourquoi il en a
marre que vous veniez faire tpp sacre à
lui mais si je me consacre à l huile de
retrait donc
arriver à castaldi
bas castadi la compétion la connaît j'ai
des saints
avec vous avec vos bêtises des gens dans
la rue marais theft ont fait voir mais
c'est vraiment de touche et
tiennent compte qu'il ya une confession
d'une confession oui vous moi j'ai un
truc c'est pas sympa ce que je faisais
quand j'ai eu le permis devant moi alors
moi je vais
je vous aime alors si là vous êtes en
plein
boom a du souci à se faire
vous êtes alors vous en appelez moi oui
j'étais pas là hier j'ai livré ce matin
13 criant ça s'est bien passé j'ai livré
tout le monde en temps et en heure je
vends découdre là j'attends que ça
c'est le temps que tu passais un client
surtout ne sais combien de temps sa
maman s'en fout
jean michel blanquer
cela pousse avant d'avoir mon permis et
après ont permis de la concession je
partais dans l'est dans la chambre de
mes parents je prenais des doubles des
clés de la renault 21 de mon père sur
baudet nevada
ça marchait près de 8 900 turbo d je
peux dire ça tapait nettoyer le filtre à
air ça marchait c'est pas ça et j'allais
à pigalle en fait et j'allais à pigalle
et je faisait la tournée des sex-shops 1
mais c'est de passer alors bas c'est là
que vous avez croisé castaldi
cette vitrine
j'avais un jeu je m'amusais à fermer la
portière tout ça continue je m'amuse à
fermer la portière avec la main et se
claquait c'est toujours ça pour gagner
du temps pour permettre l'accès revient
d'ailleurs pu y
avait marqué en énormes animaux
nouveauté non bien très bien en 97 et
une fois je sais qu'avec
une seule claque la portière de la
voiture avec les clés sur le contact à
gala une heure du matin il faut que je
rentre chez moi chercher le double c'est
dans la poche de mon père
[Rires]
sur vous si vous avez une confection moi
globalement j'étais sage comme une image
mercredi pas maintenant là peut-être
ayari ya peut-être avant-hier ou
peut-être par rapport à ma maman parce
que quand j'avais 13 ans elle est
devenue malentendantes et j'avais honte
de ça au réveillon du regard des autres
et donc disait que ma mère était
étrangère et qu'elle parlait pas
français ça comme ça on lui parlait
entre les voilà donc j'en faisais pas
possible et des bas depuis 10 mois mais
les étrangers elle comprend pas mal donc
je dirais pardon maman d'avoir eu une
explosion voilà et ben voilà rue moi
j'ai dépensé trop d'argent dans des
choses qui en valait pas la peine non
match
notamment ce soir
c'est encore une grosse marque ah oui
énorme ah ouais moi je déteste le
camouflage c'est vrai mais ça lui va
bien ah non il ne m'arrêtez durée
telle hypocrisie a pris
autant il ya des soirs il est absolument
dégueulasse
[Applaudissements]
voilà
camouflage c'est très très bon excusez
moi du camouflage alors qu'elle est
allée aucune confession sicamous fait
pas de sexe pas de sexo drôme pas de pas
d'orgie toujours pas non d'accord pas
très bien en tout cas vous êtes à côté
de moi que je pense que ça va lui faire
plaisir
mais je vous le dis voilà c'est ça les
séries